know exactly what I say or you and your
kids will not survive this night did you
get your aggression out in this ability
I feel like oh my gosh cuz you just give
it your all yes I worked out a lot of
aggression
you know stabbing people with wine
glasses and throwing chairs
[Music]
the thing that made those the stunts
tough is that we would shoot them at
four o'clock in the morning or 5:00 and
talking morning after sitting around and
you're like what my hip wait okay and
luckily I had an amazing stunt woman who
had literally just gotten off of Black
Panther so she my gosh amazing and then
will was like will Packer was like we
really need that shot of you I'm like
following up I mean wow
so they got I gave them I think I gave
them like two takes I'm like if you
don't get it you just don't you just
don't get it yeah I love doing stuff
like that side toe there was like how I
did my stunts I want to do it I want it
you know so I was excited to do it like
me getting a little workout in while I'm
working what was most fun what was most
challenging it was when I had to climb
in the Vince it was like really high
like I really had this job I was like
whoo I could possibly fall here I heard
that your prep was rose' in Pilates yes
okay so what was the ratio for a say in
Pilates we were actually filming at the
Malibu wine Safari Oh locations so the
supply was um so I'm sure there's some
cases that turned up missing
so that was hot shot probably like 70/30
got it yeah of course
gabs amazing I feel like the topics of
what it touches on african-american
strong female kicking ass so you need to
see that moms for superheroes yeah we
all know that everyday what traits do
you think superheroes and moms have in
common they figure it out yeah I usually
don't have all the resources that they
need their backs are usually against the
wall they're usually some sort of time
constrain um and they figure it out and
they figure out how to save the day I'm
just a mom
you have no clue what I'm capable of
[Music]
[Music]
you know this